So, here's what the @Index annotation looks like if
we only want the city to be indexed, but
it's not the default city. So @Index, and then
we add, if not default.class, then the index, the
property name, which is city, and then here we
just specify the default value which is default city.
And if the city Is created without a value,
it's going to get the default city as its value and
it's not going to be indexed. We can actually also
see that in the admin console on local host.
Here's two conferences that I created, and you can
see it tells us that they're not indexed, even though
these two are indexed because they have values. These
two conferences are not indexed. So, I encourage you
to explore the documentation in Objectify to learn about
different ways to conditionalize how you can index your properties.